[Music]
58 seconds of into logo verse all right
let's do this one last time
clever narration harkening back to
almost every superhero reboot having to
have an origin story is still narration
and it's still a pre origin story so
double since I'm a comic book I'm a
serial did a Christmas album at this
point can we make meta humorous in
because it feels like we should be able
to also why are the generic serials
always ending with OHS especially when
Spidey snacks
Spidey flakes and Spidey Grahams are
still on the table because the only
thing standing between this city and the
Bolivia is me frightening Lee roughly
11,000 New Yorkers say this to
themselves every morning including but
not limited to the mayor the DA random
aggressive cops deluded artists corrupt
hot dog vendors and Howard Stern Sony
headphones is only the first of many
Sony Prok placements in this otherwise
artistically original film look I get
this is the style of animation that the
movie is using to make it stand out feel
more authentically like a comic book or
whatever that doesn't make it any less
irritating that the first time I saw
this I spent twenty minutes of the movie
he's trying to figure out if it was on
purpose or if the theater employees were
too busy jerking off in people's popcorn
to pay attention to the presentation of
the film and even when I realized it was
on purpose I then spent 20 more minutes
trying to figure out why my popcorn
tasted a little extra salty hilarious
moment and it shows how much he loves
smiles but it also devastates miles
reputation at this school what is up
with these cones and this unused closest
Lane people are dropping kids off in
Lane two outside the cones are we just
shutting down lanes of traffic this
morning because it goes near a school
this five seconds of montage alone
should convince every American that we
are putting too much pressure on our
young students Christ I think I see
since we find out this gwen stacy is
from another universe how exactly did
she get into this prestigious private
school it doesn't factor in at all to
her mission or reason for being there
why would she even try to get in Jesus
Christ is it possible to have too many
references to spider-man in a spider-man
movie this movie is pointing a pretty
big arrow to yes for an egg girl walk up
to him be like hey you see you don't go
here do not do this
this is tragically bad advice thank you
I can't
character insists they won't can't do a
thing over and over only to ultimately
do that very thing cliche my biggest
problem with this time lapse is that
miles
apparently needs to pc screens a
separate laptop and a film all operating
at once at like 3:00 in the morning this
guy is either mining Bitcoin or he's
mining Bitcoin I'm not going through
puberty I did but I'm done movie was
clearly spying on my middle school
interactions with girls I'm well why
wouldn't you just say her name was Gwen
or whatever name she used to get into
this school movie not being able to
resist a moment this sitcom II deserves
ass it would be excellent at cinema
since somehow a mild sticky spider hands
rip a sticky spider hand shaped amount
of her hair off her head and no one is
going to question the stickiness of
Myles hands I know why she isn't but
everyone else should be really curious
about what's going on here how exactly
did to get all Gwen's hair from the
previous shot off of his hand
[Music]
narcs how is it possible that Gwen is
the only one looking up at this moment
to see this why is this happening please
to have sticky convenient comic book
page placement is convenient where did
the Green Goblin even go it's not as if
spider-man incapacitated him he just
swung down to help miles is that
tombstone god I love this movie is
bringing out these great underrated
characters like tombstone and the
Prowler I'm putting them on the big
screen for the first time that deserves
us in off kingpin survives this get that
damn letter to go again and so King how
it was destroyed it'll be faster to
build a new one from scratch
[Music]
maybe turn the flashlight off look at
the centerline's of this road and then
the cars parked along the right there is
no room for cars to drive in this Lane
which means this street is too canary or
else all these cars are about to get
towed for parking illegally also there
is a meets to eat on both sides of this
street and why Sears must love them some
meats to eat yeah I think it's a Banksy
Banksy ok I gotta read these comics so I
can learn how to be a spider-man so
definitely the best place for that is a
dark alley okay look if they buried
spider-man in a public cemetery and they
allowed people to visit it and drop off
trinkets and flowers then eh it would
still be overrun with people since he
literally just died and be there would
be way the hell more trinkets of flowers
here she wanted kids and it scared me
as it can shut who knows what that
spider DNA mixed with human DNA would
give birth to you could end up with Eric
Stoltz in the fly - this whole sequence
is fun and neat to look at I mean it but
it's just covering up a super dump of
exposition the snowman head was a good
gag there's no way it would stay on this
long not a costume
it was literally a ball of snow they
were just making fat jokes about his gut
a minute ago but now he looks pretty in
shape actually a lady Doc Ock is about
to make some more jokes about his gut
but my point is that the movie draws the
gut only when it needs it considering
how many times kingpin has had to go up
against spider-man
I would think Alka mechs would have some
exterior cameras pointing up to catch
moments just like this and I guess I
would be wrong but that doesn't make it
any less stupid
look at this gather okay just a second
ago this is how far above kingpin the
vent was then miles bumps into Peter
Bob's your uncle and now they're three
times closer doctor and mrs. peripheral
vision here remember this password DGF
EMP password is way longer than the one
live typed in a second ago obviously
you've been glitching glitching no well
someone saw wreck-it Ralph let me tell
you the good news we don't need the
monitor they told me about the visuals
it told me about the voice work they
even told me about the fresh original
story but they did not prepare me for
how funny was gonna be and that's a
sinful thing is there something I said
how come he only ever glitches when it's
super inconvenient or when he's talking
about glitter
spider-gwen ex machina join the band
[Music]
save my dad Bruce Wayne eat your heart
out long after the dust is settled and
the newness is worn off people will
still regardless film is fantastic but I
personally will still be trying to point
out to people how it's like 25%
expositional character introductions
because I'm a ticket
my spider-sense told me to head to
visions academy wasn't sure why until I
met you but since Gwen was in the class
Myles showed up late for that means she
was there before he was bitten by the
spider so why would her spider sense
tell her to go there do these abilities
spider sense destiny now the flashbacks
of kingpins loved ones which is also
just another rapid-fire exposition
dumped in a movie full of them would get
more emotions out of me if they dialed
back a bit on the kingpin is comically
large and his head is located where most
folks sternums would be I'm not sure how
this action prevents tombstone from
still shooting the guns that live since
there's still clearly pointed at her and
also just another Batcave you might need
these if the other Spider people have
been here the whole time then why is the
spider-sense just now lighting up I just
wash my hands that's why they're wet no
other reason well we finally got to a
joke in this movie that falls completely
flat for me he might be a real canonical
character but this is like Popeye
showing up in the middle of the
Incredibles sometimes how that matches
burn down to my fingertips just to feel
something anything this more penny ham
introduction sequence feels like one of
those SNL sketches where they do
celebrity impressions can give us fake
auditions for famous movies how did you
get here the hell same as you
why are you asking this look I made a
promise so I have to keep it promises to
dead people aren't all that important
man I promised my grandfather that I
would never forget it but I already
don't remember his name I think it was
grandpa see you no one cares can you
swing and flip with the grace of a
trained dancer do your ears hang low do
they wobble to and fro can you tie them
in a knot can you tie them in a bow you
need to be honest with yourself about
this after a test that lasted less than
two minutes at least give him a day
Jesus the one thing I will always never
understand about these parallel
dimension films is the insistence on
having everything be the exact same
width maybe one word changed what that
red X struck in the background red X
really it's more likely that there's a
FedEx in this universe and that there's
a red X in recreating the magic thumb
drive that kills the collider the
specifics of which this movie
Yatta Yatta to hell and back they took
the time to laser at the spider logo on
it because reasons this movie rules
literally everything in it is happening
too fast despite the fact that miles is
wearing a cheap Halloween costume it
remains completely under treaded after
he was dragged across a roof no mom I'm
sore you you were just keep going that's
every incarnation of spider-man have to
lose a beloved uncle what about MJ well
that new documentary really did a number
on his popularity and honestly oh you
meant Mary Jane right well several
states have legalized him and two dozen
have made it legal for medicinal
purposes but they're still along with oh
you meant Mary Jane the person didn't
you oh I know how much you want this kid
all these spider dicks teaming up to
prevent miles from taking part in the
climax because they want to protect him
assholes took you long enough it took
you long enough cliche damn this movie
has momentum and an understanding of
comic books never before demonstrated by
any movie adaptation that came before
this is a fun figuring out the power
scene but there is a timetable right
you're telling me he's had time to get
to Aunt May's spray paint the suit let
it dry and do this montage before they
could get to the collider and send
everyone home and I still taking the bus
just for comedy now oh and they sure did
clean up the mess of that last collider
accident and build a new machine in a
hurry like two days I think it was two
days that's so amazing I'm willing to
call both they do this sealing hiding
trick a lot and usually I let it go but
there's five of them including a giant
robot and those ceilings aren't that hot
there's zero chance kingpin or the two
guards didn't notice them before now so
we all realized that everyone in that
building just got transdimensional eyes
dand probably died a horrible painful
death just making sure everyone's good
with that this this is kind of fun at
all but it's just Yoda fighting Dooku
right one of the movies only problems is
sometimes leaving viewers with a bad
case of what the just happened itis at
some point this movie just said few
logic and physics and wants me to just
roll with it and for the most part I
can't still us in but it's a fun set I'd
be sad if this girl and a robot were
more than glorified cameo characters I
got the party love you first pity but
how do they know they will each go back
to their own dimension
miles letting go of Peter here after
both have finally understood their
purpose it won't be but that was the
superhero moment not whatever
ass-beating miles does after this why
would Vanessa and Richards star Tran
appearing here like most superhero films
the final few minutes turn into one big
animated ball of nonsense as they fall
all through the I guess I've seen from
interspace somehow miles that his father
are both still alive and both still in
or on things that are intact and can
both see each other from this distance
while falling into purgatory this works
my husband survives this okay let's do
this one last time yeah for real this
time if we have to okay but I remember
that scene on the bus they weren't
buddy-buddy that just met they were just
getting to know each other he said if
you ever decide to do friends again I
could open up a slot and she awkwardly
replied I'll keep you posted now is that
the kind of conversation that ends with
one of them saying let's take a selfie
together possible cannibalism what's
happening is he remembering her is she
calling to him from another dimension
it's Gwen's voice but I feel like I
should know what this means and I don't
this movie rules everyone that worked on
it deserves mention but this movie has
ten minutes of credits that's excessive
especially when the movie is going to
put in after credits scene at the end
apparently some kind of transposition
has taken place I find it extremely
interesting I know why you left but I
don't believe that I got some question
you want answers I think I'm entitled
you want a phone that girl walk up to
and be like how you doing
[Music]
hmm you don't tell me your name I'm
gonna have to make one up it's Diane
Sawyer hello I want to roll you into a
little ball and shove you up my vagina
good job wait